I'm gonna come to this this little wedge
first would you like a rap about someone
just went alright that noise is the
rudest noise you can ever make by the
way like if someone just tells you a
story and you're bored just go hmm cuz
if you go oh my they are legally allowed
to shoot you that is the rudest noise
you made just that I do not know or even
care my friend exhale so much your lips
rattled Wow
so what would you like a rap about
everyone apart from that person
Stonehenge
yeah man you rarely hear the word stone
in California with anything following it
they Stonehenge you took it there nice
so we're gonna opposite side of the room
what you guys want a rap over pimple pop
hurt did you say pimple pop hurt amazing
pimple pop hurt Stonehenge
that's great this is half of the middle
what's it gonna be orbital mechanics
yeah man coming in with someone I've
never heard of before
so it could mean two things it could
mean either in a physic sense orbits
around celestial bodies or it could mean
like hippin and socket ball and socket
joints is it either of those things or
am i way off the first one it's a shame
because I know more about the other ones
orbital mechanics pimple pop hurt
Stonehenge so far guys this is really
good let's go to this side of the middle
amazing you director by any chance
action I like it I'm gonna come right at
the back of the room so you guys often
get neglected but you you guys are there
what would you like a rap about there
were two at the same time it's probably
the back of the room people are not loud
enough could someone amplify one of
those Jurgen Klopp last week in this
very room we had to rap about Liverpool
which meant a right to lie about Jurgen
Klopp so I won't tell that suggestion
but best of luck in beating Manchester
City and I say that as someone from
Manchester and so I'm very conflicted
this this Premier League weekend it's
gonna be very difficult and the other
person said tampons
I I wish I'd taken Jurgen Klopp oh right
now so sorry though Jurgen tampons
Stonehenge pimple pop hurt orbital
mechanics and put what people probably
you could have corrected me earlier and
not like me same pimple pop her like a
wanker for the last two minutes the
words you were looking for was Papa Papa
er they're not aah yes I know what it
means I was a teenager oh no any we
don't have acne no pimple popper pimple
popper Stonehenge orbital mechanics
tampons not Jurgen Klopp and what was
the other one we got from their action
of course it was this thenn lovely
people of the comedy magic club to close
out the night with some panache and
pizzazz gonna be a freestyle rap that's
the rap made up on the spot based
entirely on those suggestions let's drop
that beat and let's get into it slightly
more than you are currently doing I'm
gonna come to you first boy someone
arrest is full maybe call the coppers
you're trying to make me look like a
tall pimple popper and when you squeeze
that and the bus goes work
and this heard that light pimple popper
like the pain that you feel when you
reveal later when you pop it so hard
slime on the ceiling we used to be a
teenage boy keeping it clean it was so
moist just like my own wet dreams but
when I've got this
yeah disgrace we waited we know the beat
went quiet oh I thought that stop then
dump it ruin the flow but that's okay
well we'll wave this drop in and then
jump right bugger this
thought the beard stopped yeah that was
the wrong one it's got the flow like a
tampon
deep down gotta go up front gotta make
sure they're seven days of the month but
one thing when you check for the block
switch it every 12 hours otherwise toxic
shock might make you so unclean you're
getting festive interesting all the
gangrene men say in fact they'd be fall
in their arms to say in Chris you
causing consternation and alarm we
didn't want to hear about this at the
show screw you blokes menstrual flow
it's what I want to talk about it's what
I wanted to and when you see an Advil
why is the liquid blue they put it on
there they show it on the screen you
just use the red liquid is still so
clean I'm keen to move away and instead
Manchester City won't stop the Ritz like
a tampon does to tampon jokes yeah
double-barrel shotgun watch me smoke I'm
going to divide two to one fraction I
sit in the high back chair action is
while scream yeah I am assured the
actors follow stuff when I do the
clapperboard I've got a big megaphone
you can check there
it says mr Turner on the back of my
chair I'm the director yes I define
action basically is when you go online
and do anything yeah I see the planet
and go I wonder if I rap about the
mechanics about the orbits of all of
them and know very little but just for
this man I'll try and have fun and say
yeah we have seen this smaller orbit of
mercury than of Venus obviously it's a
fat Akane voiceover like an American
football going round in the universe I
really wish I'd researched this and
retired to rehearse but I make it up as
I go
that is okay the last thing that I'm
gonna go down to wheelchair I'm still
there in the southwest
I Drive the a road past I know it best
cuz I used to do pigs with all of my
friends would jump in the courage shoo
down past own and they want to make sure
the road will last and so they're
building a slightly bigger bypass so you
can see the amazing land of the heritage
maybe the Druids of UK will inherit it
going down there
June 21 with the longest day the
solstice and the Sun is basically like
an ancient clock and if we not the
stones down the world might stop turning
now that's just a lie I saw there was a
new story someone returned the core they
drills fate through the lintel on top I
see those stones and Olli you are hoping
that I'll start being very specific
about English historical sites cuz no
one wanted that when they came ahead
tonight
[Applause]